the politicians the media they're all
the ben and the major corporations of
course they are the beneficiaries of
inflation
and the uh victims of inflation are
essentially duped into voting for their
own impoverishment because they're told
they're going to be getting some of the
spoils but the spoils that they get are
a tiny little fraction
of
the
wealth that gets stolen from them
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is the
author of the fiat standard and the
bitcoin standard who also runs his
online learning platform at safedeen.com
dr safety and amas welcome to
trigonometry thank you for having me
guys it's a pleasure to be here it's a
great pleasure to have you on before we
get into the conversation itself tell
everybody a little bit about who are you
how are you where you are what has been
your journey through life that leads you
to be sitting here talking to us
well um i'm palestinian jordanian and um
i got a phd in sustainable development
from columbia university and i was a
university professor in the lebanese
american university when i came across
this new interesting toy called bitcoin
and then it fascinated me and then it
drew me in like a black hole and took
over everything in my life and i left my
university job and i started teaching
online so now i'm independent
i just teach to students directly online
and i write books
and
i talk to interesting people on the
internet like you
well thank you for taking the time to
talk to us you i've listened to many
other things you've spoken about and
read some of your work uh you're very
smart man much smarter than me or
francis so
what we wanted to do is to go through
the basics for us and our audience to
get a basic understanding first of all
about money and then about bitcoin and
maybe other crypto stuff as well so
first question is what is money
the short answer is money is a medium of
exchange it's something that people buy
not for its own sake you don't buy money
because you want to eat it because you
want to look at it because you want to
use it for a certain thing it doesn't
have a function in and of itself its
only function is that you plan on later
exchanging it for something else that's
what distinguishes money from all other
goods it's something that you don't buy
for its own sake but for the sake of
exchanging it for something else and so
um
that is what we call the function of
medium of exchange because it's just
something that you use for exchange and
essentially this is something that is
developed naturally as humans um you
know as as human society became more
complex as humans lived and started
trading with more people we started
developing more products we started
living in larger societies
the idea of trading things directly for
one another becomes increasingly
impractical you know if it's just five
people on an island
then all the all the only things that
they can produce are you know maybe five
or ten things or 20 things between them
it's easy for them to keep track and to
just exchange things directly
but as the number of people grows it
becomes difficult for them to exchange
things directly for one another because
you know the thing that you want to
um you would like to acquire is uh held
by somebody who doesn't have the thing
that you want to give them and so
they don't they're not interested in
your apples but you're interested in
their oranges they're interested in
bananas so you need to find somebody who
has bananas and wants your apples and
you give them the bananas
you give them the apples you take the
bananas and then you give the bananas to
the guy with the oranges and he gives
you the oranges that you want
so um as
naturally you know as the number of
goods increases in an economy
naturally people start
buying things not for the sake of
holding them but for the sake of
exchanging them and these things are
media of exchange but over time
you know bananas do a pretty bad job of
being money because um you know they
spoil in a few days and uh
not a lot of people want bananas if the
guy that you
wanted to uh give the bananas to changes
his mind then you're not going to find a
lot of people who want the bananas so
over time
the things that end up playing the role
of money end up acquiring cert and end
up having certain properties that
make it that make them
suitable for the purposes of being a
medium of exchange of being exchanged
and
um you know some of these properties are
that it is divisible you know bananas
aren't very easy to divide into smaller
pieces
and that you can combine small pieces
into one big piece so the whole thing is
homogeneous
and another property is that it is
portable that you can move it around so
houses aren't very good as money because
you can't move a house around you can't
take it with you same is true with land
and um i think
over time though you know what ends up
uh
what ended up being the most uh
common form of money around the world by
the end of the 19th century was gold and
so in my book the bitcoin standard i
begin by explaining what it is that
makes things good as money and why is it
that gold was the world's only money at
the end of or the world's prime money at
the end of the 19th century and my
explanation for that is that the
property that matters the most for
monetary selection is
monetary hardness how hard the money is
because that determines the ability of
the money to hold on to its value over
time and in the long run that ends up
being the most important property
because you know bananas will rot
fish or any kind of food will also rot
other metals will rust and decay and
corrode but gold doesn't rust doesn't
corrode and more importantly
gold because it doesn't rust and corrode
we're constantly stockpiling more and
more gold all over the world and we're
not consuming it you know it doesn't you
you consume copper you put copper in
machines and then the machines run out
and the copper disintegrates and rusts
and is thrown away but you don't consume
gold you know you
people mined gold 5000 years ago and
that gold is still
running around the world today being
gold it's in somebody's necklace or in
somebody's gold coin it's still there it
doesn't rust it doesn't corrode it
doesn't ruin so the result of this the
implication of this is that we have
thousands of years of gold production
piling up safe thing can i interrupt
just with a very layman question what's
the difference between gold and silver
and why do we perceive gold as having
more value than silver
yep that's a great question so the
difference primarily is that uh the
silver
can tarnish and can and can ruin and it
does get used um it does get used up but
gold is not that does not ruin at all
and gold is more scarce in the earth's
crust and it's harder to find
so historically silver had a lower value
than gold um we had a bigger abundance
of silver but
those two metals were the two monetary
metals by the
beginning of the 19th century before
that you know copper and iron had been
used as money but then they lost their
monetary role as well
and the reason for that is
their monetary their non-monetary uses
or their industrial uses became pretty
significant so people were using copper
for all manner of things and that leads
to the corrosion of the copper and so
therefore what happens is if
this is why you know a lot of people say
well money is just a hallucination or
money is just a shared
a shared social contract between people
you know we can decide that we want gold
to be money or we could decide that we
want copper to be money or we could
decide we want pigskin to be money and
if we all
decide it hard enough then we can make
it money and i think that's completely
nonsense if we all decide that we want
to make copper money tomorrow it doesn't
matter how hard we
want it it doesn't matter if everybody
sells everything that they have and buys
and puts all of their and stores all of
their value in copper it's not going to
work as money and the reason is
you keep the
if we buy if we if we keep stockpiling
copper and we keep using it as a store
of value
the people who are able to mine copper
are just going to keep mining more
because the more we buy it and use it as
money the more its price goes up the
more the miners are incentivized to
produce more of it the more they produce
of it the more they bring it on the
market they crash the price so no matter
how much you want to store
copper as a store of value
eventually the mining production will
catch up with you and it will bring the
price down it's not possible to keep the
price of copper significantly high
because it's very easy for people to
make more of it
and because it rusts and corrodes and
gets used up
the quantities that we stockpile
will
you know will eventually um decline you
know they will get used up and and they
will corrode and so
new production is a large percentage
is a large percentage of existing
stockpiles this is true for all
commodities and all goods with the
exception of silver and gold
those are the two ones that manage to
maintain large stockpiles
wherein annual new production is small
compared to the existing stockpiles in
the case of silver historically this was
around
five percent so every year we add about
five percent of the stockpile of silver
a little bit of it gets consumed but we
add around five percent in the case of
gold we're adding historically around
one and a half to two percent only so
every year you're only adding one and a
half to two percent
to the stockpile of gold and every year
we get better at finding gold you know
every year we develop more machinery
better technologies for digging for gold
but what that leads to is that we um you
know we
we we never are able to make you know a
20 increase in the supply of gold
because we get marginally better this
year but then that just means that the
production of this year gets added onto
the stockpiles the stockpiles get bigger
so the production next year
even though it's bigger it's still it's
still the same kind of fraction because
the stockpot is also bigger
so that ratio of the supply increase
annually in the case of gold has always
been around one and a half to two
percent and that's why
historically i think gold became money
silver was like in second place
um
it had about a five percent growth
increase
but the advantage that silver had is
that it was more divisible than gold you
know a silver coin
is what people would use for small
day-to-day transactions whereas a gold
coin would be something that you would
use for bigger transactions so you'd buy
a house with a few gold coins you'd buy
your lunch with a silver coin
um
but over time what ended up happening in
the late 19th century is that as banking
developed
and modern banking allowed for people to
just
make financial instruments backed by
gold then it didn't matter how divisible
gold was you know we could have the
british pound backed by gold
and you could make a payment with a
piece of paper that was backed by gold
and it didn't matter you know you didn't
have to cut up the gold coin itself the
uh the pieces of paper were divisible
and so
the the use of silver as gold began to
decline toward the end of the 19th
century and then its value continued to
decline so around the mid 19th century
the price of silver in terms of gold was
15 to 1. so 15 ounces of gold 15 ounces
of silver would buy you one ounce of
gold something in that range today it's
around 100 or so so it's dropped
significantly silver's lost its value um
significantly compared to gold safe in
the 19th century just to jump in again i
know you're probably going there anyway
but it seems like we're getting to the
point of we're talking about
uh you know gold is fairly consistent in
having a certain value and you talk
about creating currencies that are
linked to gold
and then comes a point in human
development when that link is broken
and that i think is where a lot of the
modern issues we have uh that we're
probably going to talk about a little
bit so talk to us about that and and how
we got there and how that decision was
made and some of the consequences of
that
yep this is a major theme in my two
books the bitcoin standard and my second
book the fiat standard um so in the
bitcoin standard i traced the
development up until this point where
gold basically won over all the other
monies and the conclusion that i get to
is that the hardest money always wins
and we also have several other examples
you know you look at seashells
and you know when gold comes into a
society that has seashells the seashells
lose their monetary role because it's
easy
you know it's not because people just
think oh well gold is shiny and yellow
it's because people keep making more
seashells and but they can't make more
gold so the people who have gold
maintain the value of their wealth in
the gold but the people who have
seashells witness their wealth disappear
so uh it's not a matter of choice and
this is this is uh i think the main
issue that a lot of economists don't get
they tell you it's a matter of choice no
it doesn't matter how many people choose
to hold seashells
it's
it's the choice only hurts the person it
doesn't affect the consequence
inevitably gold is going to drive out
seashells your choice is whether you go
poor holding seashells or you trade your
seashells quickly while they still have
value for some gold and you managed to
maintain some wealth
so
this is what happened and i think
um i personally think this was you know
the development of the gold standard
it's not just me but a lot of people
also think the development of the gold
standard at the end of the 19th century
when the entire planet was basically
using the same money and all the global
currencies were effectively uh just
different weights of gold so there was
no exchange market as it is today where
you know the price of the dollar and the
pound and the yen are fluctuating the
dollar and the pound and the yen and the
all the other currencies were just
different weights of gold
specific number of grams of gold and so
the exchange rate hardly ever moved
there was no foreign exchange market
variation
it was just similar to the exchange
between
meters and inches and uh different units
they were fixed
so all of the world running on one
currency and that currency being hard in
my opinion is
basically the pinnacle of human
civilization at the pic at the turn of
the 20th century at the beginning of the
20th century that's when
all of the most incredible and important
inventions were invented everybody
anywhere in the world could save
money
into the future and they could be quite
confident that it would hold on to its
value you know you didn't have to be
an expert in financial markets as you
have to be today knowing understanding
stocks and bonds and commodities and
monetary policy and all these arcane
fields in order to be able to maintain
the wealth that you've earned you could
be a butcher a shoemaker you could have
any kind of job and then you get paid in
a gold coin and you just held on to that
gold coin and you knew that 10 years
down the line that gold coin would buy
you slightly more than what it bought
you when you earned it you didn't have
to go out and speculate in a stock
market casino in order to just keep the
wealth that you had
so then 1914 comes about and that's the
topic that i focus on in my second book
the fiat standard and we move from the
gold standard to the fiat standard where
effectively governments and it's it's a
long process and i describe the details
in the fiat standard and um like a lot
of bad things that have happened in the
world started all in england
[Laughter]
to be fair a lot of all good things as
well you know the steam engine and
football and the three-piece suit
you guys have done good things as well
but you know you destroyed the gold
standard which was
a terrible terrible terrible mistake
um
but that led to the replacement of gold
which had an annual supply growth rate
of around one and a half to two percent
with national currencies which in the
last 60 years you know you look at the
data from 1960 until today 2020
in those 60 years we see that the
average money supply increased at around
15 or so um
in the world
and so per year
per year yeah
wow you know yeah what's the total
increase then since
1960
it's enormous i mean it's insanely big
it is it absolutely is i mean in the
best currencies you know the better
currencies like the us dollar or the
swiss franc or the danish kroner
these kind of currencies they've
increased at around maybe
six seven eight percent on average
that's the best you know that's four or
five times the rate of increase that you
had with gold
and but of course you know you look in
the history of the 20th century you see
an enormous number of countries that
suffered hyperinflation which is
something that never happened on the
gold standard and on the all of these
hyperinflations you know the money
supply was increasing at maybe 100 200
maybe 500 in a year so the value of the
currency was getting destroyed so the
average fiat user in the last 60 years
would expect that their money would be
diluted by fourteen percent per year
that's the number that i kept yeah being
normal currency just for for late in
late person yeah government money
basically it's money because yeah it's
money because government says it's money
and safety can i ask why did the the
evil english in 1914 do this
because they wanted to fight a war
actually this is something that is
amazing they don't teach you this in
your history books and it's something
that um you know the history books in
england completely um paper over this
there was a huge inflation price
inflation that happened in england
during world war one but now you don't
talk much about it but only in 2017 you
know 100 years after
the event
did the bank of england a bunch of
people in the bank of england dug into
the basement and found a bunch of papers
that explained what actually happened
and it was published quite recently
um
and interestingly enough you know the
when the world war began and it wasn't a
world war then it was just a bunch of
european kings fighting each other then
the british wanted to interfere and the
government introduced a sale of bonds to
finance the war the english people being
you know not sociopaths did not
buy that bond issue they didn't buy a
third of the bonds so
the government had a problem on its hand
you know they wanted to go out and kill
a bunch of europeans but the english
people had better things to do with
their money than go kill europeans so
they only bought about a third of the
money that the british government needed
so what did the bank of england do well
the bank of england got a couple of
members of the bank a couple of people
who worked at the bank
high ranking officials
the bank of england basically gave them
a credit line in their own name and they
went and bought two-thirds of the bonds
in their own name
and then a certain uh
rag in england called the financial
times you may have heard of it
they published a story saying you know
the bond issue was oversubscribed and it
was extremely successful and the people
of england really do want to join this
war and it's going to be a great um
victory for england because we have all
the resources we need and of course
remember it was an august bank holiday
was going to be just you know a quick uh
a quick
tour into europe where we're going to go
and establish our dominance and come
back and that was the idea but of course
when they did that what ended up
happening is you know essentially they
issued a lot of credit money and paper
money
not backed by gold
and so as a result
the value of the paper money began to
decline and as a result they started
collecting the gold from people's uh
hands
and so they instructed the post offices
and the banks to only take payment
uh to only make payment in paper money
so and they told everybody to hand over
their gold to their local post office
and bank because that was needed for the
war effort and if you weren't doing that
then you know you were basically a
traitor effectively so with this kind of
emotional manipulation they managed to
get gold out of circulation and get
people to use the papers and of course
the consequence of that was that prices
rose so during world war one prices more
than doubled and then after world war
one there was a big recession and a big
problem in england and they were trying
to get back on the gold standard at the
old rate but they couldn't do it because
they had a whole bunch of other money a
whole bunch of new money that was
circulating
and so it's it's like a comedy of errors
where you know it's like you're watching
one of these um um slapstick comedy
movies but you know with hundreds of
millions dead people where uh you know
they make this lie and then they just
keep making bigger lies to try and cover
it up
and um the money supply keeps increasing
and that creates more problems more
inflation more economic disasters um
destroys people's livelihood destroys
people's savings
and creates you know economic recessions
and all these problems and then in order
to cover it up what do they do you know
almost like an episode of benny hill
they go and they print more money to fix
it and then it just continues to get
worse and worse
and then um
that effectively leads to britain losing
the british pound as the global reserve
currency and the dollar which was
managed by people who are slightly less
insane than the bank of england uh so it
was much stronger and got a lot of gold
flowing into the us from europe the
dollar takes over as the global reserve
currency and it becomes the global uh
money
that is you know used all over the world
but of course you know the americans
then started using that as well and then
in 1971 all the world goes off uh any
kind of link with gold where the bank of
where the u.s federal reserve
uh stops or in the us treasuries they
stop redeeming gold in
for their dollars and then there's no
limit on how much they can uh print and
so from 1971 onwards
national currencies all over the world
are backed by basically nothing it's
just governments that are just printing
and since then we see
price inflation takes off and government
debt takes off and
we just
i think you know
it's it's it's at the root of a big big
big number if not the vast majority of
economic problems all over the world
but of course it's not something that is
discussed extensively in your economics
textbooks at university because your
economics textbook is
written by people who get paid from that
printed money so they turn your
attention to all kinds of other
inconsequential [ __ ] instead
hey kkk do you believe in spring
cleaning yes but only when my wife does
it in russia men who clean are executed
for not being real men which is correct
well for those men who are living in the
21st century manscaped has an incredible
offer for you manscaped are the global
leaders immense below the ways grooming
and have forever changed the grooming
game with their amazing performance
package 4.0
inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawn mower 4.0 trimmer weed
whacker ear and nose hair trimmer crop
preserver ball deodorant crop provider
turner performance boxer brief and a
travel bag to hold your goodies this
elite trimmer is designed to trim hair
on loose skin although your werewolves
might look like a couple of boris
johnsons treat them with respect and
benefit from their proprietary
skin safe technology complete your
grooming game this spring with the new
refined cologne signature scent by
manscaped this stuff is legit and will
have you smelling like royalty the good
kind not prince andrew get 20 off and
free shipping with the code trigger20 at
manscape.com
the start of spring also marks the start
of testicular cancer awareness month in
april manscape has partners with the
testicular cancer society to bring
awareness to testicular cancer men's
health and early cancer detection
manscape is committed to raising
awareness for the most common form of
cancer in men aged 15 to 35 our age
exactly and giving support for fighters
survivors and families impacted by
testicular cancer as part of their we
save balls initiative gents you now have
the perfect excuse to check yourself on
a regular basis get stuck in
that's a huge worry for the world isn't
it particularly as because in the covert
era we've all been printing huge amounts
of money and before that in 2008 and by
the way can i just say before you answer
that question as an honorary englishman
now i've got no problem with my money
going to annoy europeans or whatever
mess it up that's that's very much on
brand for us
yeah it's true it is a major problem
it is a major problem all over the world
i think um you know it's it's it's
amazing when you if you follow the news
over the last year in particular you
know inflation is rising everywhere
prices of everything is going up now
listen to the mainstream media listen to
the phds in economics
why is this happening there's an
infinite number of reasons that they'll
bring up you know it's happening because
of supply chain disruptions and it's
happening because of the virus and it's
happening because of this and that and
the other thing
and it's you know it's all distraction
from the one very very obvious cause
which is that the money supply just
keeps going up and it's you know you
look at the rate of increase in the
money supply it's just always going up
it's it's gone up vertically over the
last couple of years but it had always
been going up and the problem with this
inflationism is it's like a drug
addiction
where you know that there's no such a
thing as a moderate heroin user um it's
it's addictive so you need more and more
and more and so even if initially let's
say in the 80s
inflation seemed like it was under
control in the 80s and the 90s well
inflation
the the more it seems like it is under
control the more tempting it is to
engage in more of it and then the more
you engage in it the more problems you
create and then if you think that
inflation can solve those problems
then you're going to try and solve the
problems of inflation with more
inflation which is what they're doing
and i think it is a huge problem it's
something that um
proper economists
what i like to think of as proper
economists you know are the alternative
schools of economics the austrian school
of economics which is what i consider
myself
a part of they've been harping on about
this for more than a century now that
this is the biggest problem in
the world economy and they are
marginalized
because you know there's a lot of very
powerful interests that benefit from
money printing and so um they'd like to
deflect away from this
and focus on you know all other uh other
kinds of inconsequential [ __ ] but
now
it's you know the world's waking up onto
the fact it's very hard to it's becoming
harder and harder for establishment
economists and central bank to continue
to make the astonishingly absurd lie
that no no no our money printing is
helping
fight the price inflation we're not
responsible for the price inflation the
reason prices are rising is because of
other things and our money printing is
how we're fixing this
it's becoming less and less tenuous in
many more people's minds and if we
if we you know the people of england or
the people of britain or the people of
america went to the ballot box and we
had a a choice of somebody who wanted to
bring us back onto the gold standard is
that even possible now or if we just are
we just too drugged up now and there's
no way out
um i think theoretically it is possible
like if you voted for somebody yeah he
could do it it would uh
it would require a massive revaluation
of gold so the price of gold would go up
to maybe something like 10 000 pounds an
ounce or twenty thousand pounds an ounce
so theoretically it is possible but
practically and politically it's
impossible so if you look at somebody
like ron paul in the us
um you know
he had a lot of grassroots support but
he could not translate that into
political effective
success
because um and this this is really the
really pernicious thing about this it's
a
it's it's a very sustainable equilibrium
because
once
once you once you've started printing
money then the people who are in
government have an enormous amount of
power over society
and so
they are able to use that power in order
to get themselves re-elected and if
you're going in with the agenda of i am
not going to use the money printer
it's kind of like going into war without
a weapon you know because um politics is
the weapon
you know democracy is
i'm going to give you free ponies and
free hospitals and all of the nice
things that you want you know and so the
more promises you make the more votes
you get so if you run on the platform of
screw you i'm not going to give you
anything you're going to have to work
for things you're not going to make it
in politics so a lot of people have
tried and there have been a lot of
economists a lot of politicians who have
run on this kind of hard money let's go
back to gold platform but it's a dead
end the bureaucracy
the politicians the media they're all
the and the major corporations of course
they are the beneficiaries of
inflation
and the uh victims of inflation are
essentially duped into voting for their
own impoverishment because they're told
they're going to be getting some of the
spoils but the spoils that they get are
a tiny little fraction
of
the
wealth that gets stolen from them and
that's the perniciousness of the scam
you know so you're witnessing your
savings destroyed
you're witnessing your ability to save
for the future destroyed
and you're willingly giving it up
because you're voting for people who are
promising you you know we're going to
give you free this and free that um
but uh you know we see what how this
ends up uh it ends up with a lot of um
you know nothing is free at the end of
the day you're just promising these
things to be done with central planners
central plan is going to be doing those
things and it's going to
end up being more and more expensive and
it's going to end up destroying the
currency even more so
i don't really think that
political solutions are
possible
this is a job for superman this is a job
for bitcoin
okay and we segue nicely into bitcoin so
look here's the thing safety in i think
it was in
2011 a friend of mine told me uh he gave
me two pieces of advice get into silver
and he said get into bitcoin buy bitcoin
and obviously me being skinned as a skin
comedian i i didn't have the option of
doing it i had no idea what bitcoin is
i still don't really understand what
bitcoin is can you do a basic layman
explanation of what bitcoin is and
actually why it's so powerful in today's
economy
yeah so bitcoin um you know the
i'm not going to get into the technical
aspect of it because it's going to take
a lot of time to go into that so i'm
just going to discuss it functionally
you know i'm not going to explain how
the car works i'm just going to tell you
what a car does
um and the importance of bitcoin is that
it is a form of money it's a digital
form of money that exists on the
internet that is controlled by and
nobody nobody is in charge of bitcoin
it's a protocol that um anybody can use
but nobody can control so it only has
users it doesn't have admins
and the really really important thing
about it which is the focus of my first
book the bitcoin standard is the idea of
hardness remember when i said uh gold is
the hardest money one and a half percent
increase well bitcoin is even harder
than gold it's um becoming harder it's
now increasing at around two percent it
started off increasing at a pretty high
percentage uh
rate of increase but that rate declines
over time and now it's at two percent
and it's going to continue to decline
and then eventually it's going to uh
arrive at a growth rate of zero so
there's only ever going to be 21 million
bitcoin there's no way of making more
than 21 million so we've already made
almost 19 million
at the time
currently and there's only going to be
another 2 million bitcoin that are going
to be made over the next century or so
so the supply growth rate of bitcoin has
already dropped significantly it's
around the same range as gold right now
and in the next few years is going to
decline below gold and it's going to
continue to decline until it eventually
hits zero and then stops growing
so um
what i'll say if you want the details
for why you should read my book but
basically this is extremely credible
there's no way of anybody finding a way
of
making more bitcoin it doesn't matter
how many petitions you sign it doesn't
matter how many media how many
university professors how many academics
how many keynesian textbooks you write
you can't make more bitcoin and so
that's why bitcoin basically you know
it's it solves the problem of politics
we don't have to um
we don't have to
convince the crazy inflationists anymore
we don't have to reason with them we
don't have to win elections against them
this is money that just doesn't give a
[ __ ] about what anybody thinks it's just
going to be there and it's only going to
be 21 million
and your only option is to deal with it
or as bitcoiners like to say cry harder
there's nothing you can do to change it
or well
on that point safety i don't understand
bitcoin or money nearly as well as you
do but i understand people and politics
i think reasonably well and the one
thing i know is if a government has an
incentive to
punish you or to prevent you from doing
something or to find a way to to prevent
you from doing the things that they
don't want you to do they will
eventually at least very very hard look
for a way very very thoroughly and very
very hard and i don't know if they can
prevent you from making more bitcoin or
force you to make more whatever but what
they can do is prevent you from using it
somehow right there must be a way they
can prevent you from buying things from
selling things there must be a way they
can punish you they can make it illegal
for example right so isn't that a real
concern going forward it's like okay i
hear you it's a really hard currency
it's not going to increase by more than
specific amount it's a very easy medium
of exchange it can be broken up like it
works in the way that money works
but isn't it if it's in direct
directly against the interests of the
people who run our world they will find
a way to prevent it from fulfilling that
destiny weren't they
um
perhaps but i think you know the more
you look into how it functions the more
difficult it is to find a way in which
they can stop it because ultimately
yeah this thing was built precisely with
the objective of resisting capture and
attack by government so it's not
optimized for your user experience it's
not optimized for
ease of use it's not an apple iphone
it's uh you know it's it's not this cute
app on your phone that is just
blowing your mind and how cool it is
it's not netflix it's not apple it's an
ugly contraption you know think about it
as like this
ugly machine that you use to make a
dirty job
to pull off a dirty job but it does the
job that you want
and that job is resisting capture by
central authority and so
the key thing to understand here is that
there's no single point of failure in
bitcoin there's no s uh there's no
trusted party there's nobody who is a
critical
um who is critical for the operation of
bitcoin there's nobody you could kill to
kill bitcoin there's no building you can
bomb to destroy bitcoin there's no
headquarters there's no single computer
there's no single server anywhere in the
world that you can take out and then you
take out bitcoin bitcoin is essentially
a bunch of code and so anybody who runs
that code on their machine is able to
join the bitcoin network
so there are maybe 10 billion internet
capable devices around the world between
phones and laptops and servers and so on
any of these just needs to
run the code
of bitcoin
and find a way of connecting to other
machines
through the internet and maybe not even
through the internet itself you know
they could connect through
uh radios and you could connect through
mesh networks you know not necessarily
through the internet but through just
connecting through other computers that
connect to other computers
with these kind of networks you
you will be able to
basically do bitcoin so
what it would take to show something
else safety and sorry my question is at
the end of the day if money is a medium
of exchange
and governments control whether you can
convert bitcoin into their money because
that's what you're going to have to
convert it into to buy stuff right
they don't cut you off that's that's the
key thing like eventually you don't have
to i mean you don't have to convert
bitcoin into
pounds in order to buy things you can
just give somebody bitcoin and they give
you things
and so the truth can i can are we ever
going to get to a point sorry to keep
interrupting i just want to hone in on
this
are we ever going to get to a point
where you can save all your life savings
in bitcoin and then be able to buy a
house if the government in that country
has banned transactions in bitcoin
because it thinks they're immoral or
illegal or undermining the economic
system or whatever they've decided
bitcoin's not allowed in our country am
i ever going to be able to buy a house
well i think you know the the example
here to look at is uh
if you look at your average uh country
that has experienced hyperinflation over
the past uh century and there's many of
them
uh when the currency begins to collapse
and when there are problems you know
people naturally move away from their
local currency to dollars and pounds or
euros
and they start using these currencies
and of course governments will
clamp down on these currencies and they
will stop uh they will ban people from
using them
but
what that does is the exact opposite
effect so when you say you can't buy
dollars with you know our peso or our
whatever it is well then what happens
you're not going to destroy the dollar
you're just going to destroy your local
uh [ __ ] coin basically so
you're just saying that this currency
cannot buy real money and so people who
hold this currency now
value it less and they want to get rid
of it more and they don't want to get
paid in it
so
that's uh that's i think the reality in
uh if you so
um even if
major governments decide to ban bitcoin
you know that just gives a massive
advantage to other governments to go and
accumulate bitcoin or uh people in other
countries to accumulate bitcoin hold on
to it
and then um you know the people who are
forced to use the
uh inferior currencies of their
governments are just going to witness
their wealth
destroyed and the people who use bitcoin
are going to witness their wealth
accumulate and i have several examples
of this happening with gold and silver
so for instance at the late 19th century
china and india were the last two
countries that were on a silver standard
and that was a massive massive mistake
for which they're still paying i think
until today because the value of silver
continued to decline while the rest of
the world was on gold and so that's what
allowed the british and the europeans to
essentially economically dominate china
and india because their money was
appreciating while the chinese and
indian money was depreciating and so
everything just got cheaper for
foreigners in china and india so they
could keep buying more and more things
and this is uh this is effectively what
you would be doing as a government if
you ban
bitcoin you're
you're basically
um
picking the seashells you're going with
seashells and saying yeah we're just
going to ban our peasants from using
gold coins and then we'll be able to
keep
them on the seashell standard and then
gold will just go away
i don't think that's going to work
safety and what would you say to those
people who go look you look at the
fluctuations of bitcoin you know it will
surge and then it will crash
etc it's not stable it's not reliable
and actually it's quite reckless to
invest a lot of money in it
uh generally what bitcoiners say to
those people is have fun staying poor
this is the kind of very common uh
attitude
the idea is yes it is volatile of course
but it is volatile going up so the
long-term trend is always up you know
bitcoin's never been down on a three or
four year horizon it's always going up
it's uh going up in many multiples of
its value so yes if you hold your local
national currency
it doesn't fluctuate as much
as bitcoin
but
it's trending down in real terms you
know look at the price of houses in your
local town in terms of your local
currency anywhere in the world you know
houses just keep it getting more and
more expensive every year well why we
keep building more and more houses and
the technology to make houses continues
to get more efficient so we have
you know in real terms houses are less
expensive we make them much more
efficiently today and yet the price of
houses continues to go up it's not the
price of the house that's going up it's
the value of the currency that is going
down and so if
so
if you hold on to your national currency
for the long run and even if you try to
beat
the inflation by investing in stocks or
bonds
you're basically not beating inflation
it's very difficult to beat real
inflation when i say inflation i don't
mean the cpi number or the you know
consumer price inflation statistics that
the government puts out which is
just another form of fictional
statistics from government i mean the
real inflation you know think about the
house your house of dream the house of
your dreams where you'd love to live and
think about the price of that house you
know look it up online if you can
and see what has happened to the price
of that house over the last 10 years it
is going up by much more than the cpi
number think about all the things that
you actually desire the things that you
really want you know
the value of
precious goods it's going up much higher
than inflation
and that's not uh the thing becoming
more valuable it's the money becoming
less valuable so
the answer to this is yes bitcoin's
volatility is a problem in the short
term
if you want to hold bitcoin for the
short term it is a problem if you have a
lot of exposure to bitcoin in the short
term
um and you know you have short term
liabilities like if you're a business
and you have to make
payments then yeah it is a tricky thing
you don't want to be fully in bitcoin
because um you might not be able to make
your payroll at the end of next month so
you do still need to hold
some of your local operating some of
your currency for your operating
expenses
but if you want to think about the long
term you know if you want to hold money
for the next 5-10 years
bitcoin is really the best option and so
you have to have a long-term perspective
on it and you have to ignore the
day-to-day noise and essentially
understand that what we're witnessing is
that this thing is just continuously
going up
and it's going up because the supply is
fixed there's no way of making more of
it and so
um
you know the sooner you get in the more
you're going to have and the more you're
going to benefit and the less you're
going to suffer from your local
inflation but of course you may not want
to get in all in initially because of
the volatility particularly if you're a
business
i think perhaps that might be
understandable but
in the long run
what you think about what you want to
what what you want is you want to
maintain value you want to or increase
the value and bitcoin really does this
better than anything else
hi francis do you have your own business
no what do you think trigonometry is an
opportunity for me to annoy people and
shout catch phrases birds love it one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten
well if you do run your own company
you'll know how important branding is to
have a successful business that's why
you should work with the older files
every project is carefully considered
and tailored to ensure your brand is
consistent and memorable to everyone it
reaches most big city agencies are going
to cost you an arm and a leg just so
they can pay their overhead costs the
older files work remotely so you don't
have to worry about being overcharged
not only that there they're a one-stop
shop for all your branding needs
including brand development online ad
design email design web design print
design motion graphics and more they do
design guys visit the older files dot
com forward slash triggered and fill out
the project request form to get 10
percent off your first project and a
free consultation that's the order files
dot com slash triggered and get 10 off
your first project and free consultation
we have the saying here in the uk which
is safe as houses and you've alluded to
the the house price inflation that we
are seeing
how would you say bitcoin will compare
to something like property over a 10 15
20 year period
i think uh i mean we look at the past
it's done much better than property and
i think it's likely going to continue to
outperform uh property um
and i think you know a big
part of the reason why property
continues to increase is that people use
their houses as their saving accounts
under the gold standard you had a
savings account which was backed by gold
and um you would invest you would buy
the house that you'd need and you would
just uh um
buy the house that you needed as a
consumption good
now people think of their houses as
their savings accounts you know this is
where i put my wealth and you maybe over
invest in housing because if you have a
lot of money you know you'd rather have
that money in a house than have it in a
bank right it's a better investment or
you buy more houses and you rent them
out which leads to the situation where
people who have money end up with a lot
of houses and people who are young and
who are just getting started they can't
afford to buy houses because their
passes are being bid up by the people
who already have the money because
they're using them as a saving account
so you know young people the reason that
young people can't afford housing and
they need to get into you know enormous
amounts of debt is that you're not just
bidding against other people who want to
buy a house you're bidding against
people who want to buy
and save
an investment saving account exactly
and i think the interesting thing is
that bitcoin is going to obsolete this
use case for houses so i think the long
run
it's gonna you know more and more people
are discovering that you're better off
putting your money in bitcoin than
putting it in a house therefore i think
over time that's just going to return
housing to being a consumer good where
people buy the houses that they need to
live in not the houses that they uh
you know not saving accounts you use
bitcoin as a saving account
safety i think one of the issues that
people have with bitcoin is it it seems
to be because it's such a new thing
there seem to be a lot of scam artists
that you hear all these stories about
people being scammed uh you know i i got
an email sent by my bank and now you can
question the bank's motives for this but
basically saying there's a lot of people
out there using bitcoin using crypto as
a way to scam others
is this being overstated or is this a
problem in the market
no i think it's true i think it's uh
it's it's a new technology and it's very
difficult for uh people to figure it out
quickly you need a lot of time you need
to spend a lot of time uh figuring it
out and understanding it
um you know nobody has uh nobody's born
understanding bitcoin you need to spend
a lot of time understanding it so that
is
that creates a very rife environment for
people to take advantage of people who
are not very familiar with what's going
on
and personally i think um you know my
personal opinion is that all the other
digital currencies are effectively scams
um
that they're uh
they pretend to be decentralized like
bitcoin
and that allows them to sell themselves
as being the equivalent of bitcoin but
they're not decentralized only bitcoin
has truly managed to be decentralized
because
you know you look at the history of how
bitcoin is developed the guy who made it
he was anonymous he didn't nobody knew
who he was it was just one person
um and he made it he you know he he put
it uh online for anybody to use and then
other people started to use it and then
he disappeared and nobody knows who he
is nobody knows uh what happened to him
um he may be dead he may have just you
know gotten rid of that identity and
moved on with his life but the important
thing is that it's now been 11 years
that he's been disappeared so
the
the person the only person who could
control bitcoin has been gone for 11
years and bitcoin has been running for
11 years
so we can and in those 11 years a lot of
people have tried to take control of
bitcoin a lot of people have tried to
make changes to bitcoin and they've all
failed
bitcoin continues to
refuse to be controlled and so therefore
when i say 21 million bitcoin i know
there's going to be only 21 million
bitcoin i'm you know i'm comfortable
going out there in public and putting my
name out and saying this is what's going
to happen
and i know that if one day there's going
to be more than 21 million bitcoin i
want to have an entire bucket load of
egg on my face
but i'm willing to take this chance
because i think
really the the you know the mold's been
broken and there's no way to
make another bitcoin there's no way to
mess with bitcoin that's not the case
with all the others once bitcoin was up
and running
it was the real thing it was
decentralized nobody could control it
and then if anybody came about and built
us another one
them building another one was only going
to um work and is only going to succeed
if they were able to be in charge of it
if they were able to be
handling it and that's why basically
with all the other currencies you know
it only takes you 15 minutes of digging
to figure out who are the people behind
it and
it's entirely
easy for the people behind it to change
the supply change the rules and we've
seen that happen with pretty much
most of the big currencies that they're
run like startups whereas bitcoin is a
neutral protocol bitcoin is like a
language you know who controls the
english language nobody there's no
authority that can say what is the
english language and to the extent that
there are authorities that write
dictionaries you know they don't make up
new words
new words emerge and then they
incorporate them into the dictionary so
um
this is what bitcoin is like whereas all
the others are um i i believe
centralized and i think therefore
they're
they're essentially fraudulent because
they're marketing themselves as
decentralized but really they're just
securities it's a bunch of people
issuing financial liabilities
sorry oh sorry so you'd say even a big
currency like ethereum which loads of
people have bought into you know which
has become pretty much mainstream you
would say that that is
not
not a good investment
no i i would not recommend anybody put
any money in any digital currency other
than bitcoin
and safety uh it's really interesting
you've explained things so brilliantly
in in a way that's simple to understand
and i really appreciate and your books
do a great job of that as well can we
talk a little bit about since you're
making predictions about the moment that
we find ourselves in right now as a as a
world particularly the western world
uh so let's just go back a little bit
2008 you know we have a massive
financial crash our solution is to print
a [ __ ] ton of money and give it away
mainly to banks and to ourselves right
then and then and then we we have uh you
know zero interest rates or maybe even
negative interest rates depending on how
you want to look at it for however many
years it's been 14 years now um
then we have coved when we go okay well
look we've got this disease let in i
don't know what you guys did over there
but in this country what we did is we
went stay at home the government's going
to give you [ __ ] loads of money that
we're going to print right now you know
world war three if we all survived that
like where are we gonna be because you
know we had people on the show two years
ago going inflation's coming it's coming
and it's it's been
coming and now it's here like what's
happening economically and what is the
future going to look like
i mean um i don't have a crystal ball so
i i i don't really know um and i'm
worried about making predictions in the
future but i think
um betting on these very strong very
persistent uh decades-long
trends to continue is probably the best
bet i think we're just going to be more
the same we're going to have more money
printing more inflation more devaluation
of the currency more price rises
and um i think the dangerous thing that
we're seeing
increasingly is that the more this money
printing we get the more power the
government has and i think you know the
last two years just the insanity of the
idea that government can just decide all
right we don't want you to get sick so
you know screw your business screw your
life screw everything that you care
about you just need to stay home and
we're gonna lock you up i think this is
just completely
insane
and i think it's something that can only
happen when a government has this insane
tool that is a money printer and so uh
you know a lot of people would say well
what would happen if we were on a
bitcoin stand a lot of people have asked
me this question what would happen if we
were on a bitcoin stand and then covert
comes along how do you expect the
government to shut down the world and
give people free money and the answer is
exactly they won't shut down the world
and then people would have to make their
own choices and i believe in a world in
which people had to make their own
choices
covert would have been dealt with
extremely far more efficiently i think
doctors would have done a much better
job than what happens now when all these
you know
essentially
uh
non-medical bureaucrats were making
decisions for millions of people rather
than letting doctors and patients make
their decisions for themselves and we
saw this with a lot of these medicines
which i'm not going to mention because i
don't want to get your youtube channel
canceled but you know there's a lot of
these medicines that came about that
were proving very effective and many
doctors were speaking about them
but the bureaucrats
had they didn't see any power in it and
so they were promoting the measures that
involve power and submission and
compliance and dependence you know they
want to shut down your business so that
you need the government for their money
and then you'll have to vote for the
government to give you more money and
then they'll be able to control you
politically and they'll be able to
control you more and more so i think
it's a very very dangerous world and um
another aspect of it is just the the
amount of government propaganda that
we're seeing and the ability of the
government to just brainwash everybody
into marching along
with everything that they want is
extremely dangerous i think it's uh
sadly i think things are just going to
keep getting worse and
of course you know nobody knows how
things are going to get worse i mean uh
you know if i asked you
five years ago
what's going to happen in 2022 you know
you wouldn't have imagined that there's
going to be a big war of russia and
ukraine you wouldn't have imagined there
was going to be a virus and break off
um
these things just come out of nowhere
and they show up so i think you know
we're going to be getting more and more
of these kind of
dramas in the next upcoming seasons of
fiat world
um and things are gonna keep getting
worse and worse until bitcoin fixes
things and i think it's just um we need
more and more people are gonna wake up
to bitcoin and they're going to join
bitcoin not because of
you know not because of ideology not
because they want to fight the
government they want to take money out
of the government they're going to join
bitcoin because it uh appreciates and it
gives them um you know it protects them
from inflation it makes gains you know
we call it number go up technology the
price of bitcoin keeps going up people
can come for the number go up and the
more people join for the number go up
the more bitcoin rises in value
and the more that this free-market
monetary system grows
as an alternative to the clown world of
fiat
um that is just uh threatening to
nuke
all of existence into oblivion
um and i you know it's a it's a it's
like the final scene of a movie where
will the hero manage to rescue the
uh sweetheart before the bomb goes off
in the building or not i think this is
where we are right now so stay tuned
[Laughter]
and on that wonderfully positive note
safety it's been it's been a great
episode and thank you interview and
thank you so much for coming for
explaining to us and uh illuminating not
only myself but also our audience as to
what bitcoin is and the potentials of it
uh yeah i knew all about bitcoin safety
in in about i can't remember when it was
probably about 2011 something like that
i bought 400 quid 400 pounds worth of
bitcoin and then a few years later it
doubled it doubled to 800 pounds and
triumphantly i sold it what what a
legend and now that amount that i had i
think it was like half a bitcoin or
something is worth about 20 grand uh so
i knew i knew even less than nothing
about it so thank you for coming on and
talking about it uh listen we've got
before we ask you our questions from our
supporters on locals only uh we have our
usual question which is the one we ask
all our guests uh which is what is the
one thing we're not talking about as a
society that you think we really should
be
um
i'm going to go with meat i think people
should be eating more meat
and yes government is constantly telling
you that you need your grains and you
need your veggies and you need your
fruits i think that's all [ __ ] they
want you to eat all that crap because
it's cheaper and um eating meat is
expensive and then it brings up
inflation numbers so for the last 50
years since we moved on the fiat
standard and i discussed this in detail
in my book
governments have been
telling people to eat [ __ ] basically
because they want to cover it up and
then all these industrial food
manufacturers have
developed massively profitable business
models of feeding people uh industrial
waste which they make highly addictive
and the way to beat that is to eat meat
i've eaten nothing but meat for the last
six and a half years and it's been the
best thing that has ever happened to me
so
i i eat only meat literally only meat
and water that's all i eat and i highly
recommend it um you won't hear your
nutritionist talk about it because your
nutritionist's
nutrition department is financed by
industrial uh food manufacturers
and if you eat meat you don't desire the
industrial junk that makes them a lot of
money so
our producer is a passionate vegetarian
we're called trigonometry for a reason
he's walking off now i can see that's it
he's left he's folded his uh his arms
and he's furious yeah yeah
uh so that's fantastic so safetying.com
for your lectures the bitcoin standard
and the fiat standard your two great
books we're going to ask you a couple of
questions but with that thank you so
much for coming on trigonometry and
thank you all for watching and listening
we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one or raw
show all of them go out at 7 pm uk time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
how concerned is safety by the canadian
government seizing the truckers crypto
wallets
and the uh and the incoming regulations
aimed specifically at crypto